joining us from our los angeles studio
we have been waiting for her to grace us
with her presence please welcome me
incredible
oh my gosh
you you get better with every year of
your life um oh my gosh
oh my
it's true and we both we both have been
at this for a very long time um and what
do you attribute
the
renaissance
to
um i mean i don't know but true this
business is so weird like i had no you
know i've just been lucky you know i
feel like i've just been kind of one
foot in front of the other and you have
no idea
what's gonna be on the other side of
whatever and you never can hold on to
anything too too tightly and so
i'm just kind of enjoying this second
and i don't have social media so that
kind of it's all kind of feels weird
anyway but it's been a blast and the
fans are so sweet so it's been a really
like
really tender tender time
can i ask why you don't go on social
media why you have abstained abstained i
it started to be totally honest out of
just sheer laziness and just not knowing
how to figure it out i have a file of
facts so that's who we're dealing with
but then there's a whole lot of i've got
teenagers i just think there's a whole
lot of like
stuff that i think i myself as a human
feel good
separating myself from you have
teenagers
and yeah what is their life on social
media like so they have like definitely
limits on their social media of course
and it's very all private and it's all
like you know they had to write
contracts
i mean we wrote contracts that they had
to sign like that this phone is ours
you're allowed like you're borrowing it
like we're allowed to look at anything
that you put on this at any time so
they've both been like pretty pretty
okay so far with like the
this the kind of on so far i mean so far
it's all moving so freaking fast i know
and this is why i wanted to pick your
brain about it because i allow my kids
on social media and they're younger
they're seven and nine but i really want
to keep them kids and i don't meet i
it's really refreshing for me to talk to
another parent who like makes contracts
with their kids and wants to protect
them i love this
well i mean i think it's a lot of it for
me is because i'm just from ohio and so
there's just like uh there's like i just
think for me it's like this is like what
it is like we didn't have like you know
you're i i
you know i went and played outside like
i just my
for me it was just all about my
imagination so like i would come home
from school i wouldn't see my parents
until dinner and then i would just go
back to playing and like i want them to
have that same experience and that
didn't involve
phones for me well you came from ohio
and had your play and imagination and
wanted to have them have old world
values the way you did i came from
hollywood and was like out of nightclubs
and we had completely different
experiences and yet i think our parents
really meets at a very similar place
yeah i love it interesting well
something sparked with your daughter and
led her to baking is this true yes no
she is an uh legit incredible baker
she's very passionate about baking and
about animal um she's a real animal
advocate so she has like a password
protected website where you can buy you
know baked goods and all the proceeds
she'll she says on a disclaimer all
proceeds from your purchases will go to
uh the kitty bungalow animal shelter
which is like i don't think she knows
what disclaimer means exactly but
okay
so
there is proof right there that you have
done something really amazing with your
parenting if your kid
is doing animal philanthropy
yeah and doing fake sales
congratulations
what a relief
do you know was there like a connector
like a light bulb like an aha moment or
was she born like dr doolittle
she's like dr dude like i'm telling you
every saturday night either my husband
or i are spending our time volunteering
at a cat shelter that's my saturday
night drew because she's a minor
i do
i love that
i could use a saturday night one of
these days but it means so much to her i
think we have a vet in our future i i
have to ask about um the agatha house of
harkness show
that is the spin-off from wandavision
this is going to be so huge is there
anything that you can tell us
even though i'm sure you have a marvel
muzzle
what can we know what can we know i mean
i didn't even know the title of the show
until it was released to the public like
they keep it so tight is there a
possibility that mephisto might be
making some type of appearance i keep
hearing that i have
no idea that was like a big thing during
wanda vision but i have no i who knows i
mean i think right now like anything
like marvel i mean who knows it's
anything as pr is probably possible but
like i have never heard anything
definitive about that at all if you
could ask anyone as mephisto
who would you pick if you are in the
driver's seat and you know agatha gets
to pick her mephisto
would there ever be anyone who fits the
bill
[Laughter]
i mean
all i'll say in terms of a real great
deflection of that question
is
is that
there is something that does feel so
badass to be playing
like you know we think of a witch
and you think of a you know immediately
you think of a woman
who is loud who is mysterious who is
dangerous because she's complicated and
she's misunderstood
and all that stuff is a real turn on to
me as a performer in terms of digging
into
this
this person a little bit more very
excited well everyone will be hanging on
every detail that comes through
manifestos out of this
nice
the shrink next door um casey wilson
came on the show and i actually did her
makeup i'm so in love with her
i was like no
her the whole time
um isn't she the dearest softest
sweetest kindest i love her i loved her
in the show and i love this show
and i love that your character
encourages your brother will ferrell to
seek a shrink
and then
yeah
yeah no good deed
goes unpunished i think paul rudd i know
so
this is one of my favorite things i've
ever seen him in he is different in this
show yeah he's so good there's the
facial expressions
this jewish therapist that he plays like
the mensch type of
seemingly person that he is in the
beginning and how it all grows i've
never seen paul rudd in this
form his body language is different his
[Music]